[Musique]
aujourd'hui le monstre du rhône
on
ils semaient la terreur sur les rives du
fleuve
il se nourrissait de chair humaine et
dans cette région sauvage de la vallée
du rhône les habitants vivaient
épouvanté c'était un monstre
il s'appelait le brame quand il fonçait
sur ses proies
on l'entendait pousser un horrible
mugissement pareil à celui d'un taureau
en colère alors les villageois se
cachait dans leur maison se bouchait les
oreilles les feuilles des arbres
elle-même frissonner le bras me
ressemblait à un énorme dragon
ils avaient le corps couvert des cas et
de zèle lourde en forme de nageoires
coupante hérissés de piquants qui lui
permettait à la fois de voler de nager
au bout de son long cou se dressait une
tête cruel ses naseaux lançait des
flammes ses yeux brillaient comme des
lames de poignard ses pattes évoqué
celle d'un aigle géant à cause de leurs
griffes recourbé qu'il à céret les
proies ses mâchoires effrayante
s'ouvrait sur des dents de requin et
puis ce cri
[Musique]
ce cri terrible qui glaçait jusqu'aux os
le brame aimait chasser près du barrage
un barrage que l'on avait construit pour
garder une partie des eaux du rhône et
les lui rendre on était quand son niveau
baissait ainsi le fleuve pouvait en
toute saison servira la navigation mais
en dehors des heures où il chassait le
brame vivait dans le lit du rhône c'est
là sous l'eau qui l'emportait ces
captures de malheureuses lavandières qui
frottait leur linge sur les rives des
bergers des pêcheurs et aussi des
bateliers car le brame d'un coup de rein
faisait chavirer les barques qui
transportait les gens et les
marchandises d'une rive à l'autre du
fleuve on racontait que le monstre
dévorer ses victimes dans sa caverne au
fond du rhône et qu'il entreposait les
sacs de blé les tonneaux de vin les
bouteilles d'huile tomber débarque
renversé mais personne n'avait vu cette
caverne
car jamais personne dans l'été revenus
cependant des débris de vêtements
rejetée à la surface laisser supposer le
pire
un après midi d'automne guillaumat
garçon de 15 ans pousse à son troupeau
de vaches un peu plus loin que
d'habitude vers l'euro là où nul n'osait
plus s'aventurer à cause du brame
guillaume habitait avec sa mère julia
une maison isolée à deux ou trois cents
mètres du fleuve julia était veuve elle
ne possédait que quelques pâture or les
bêtes avaient faim voilà pourquoi malgré
le danger
guillaume laisse à ses vaches peut être
non loin du rhône là où l'herbe était
encore grâce le garçon chantait pour
passer le temps il avait une voix belle
et joyeuse et le soir tombait guillaume
se préparait à rentrer ses vaches à ce
moment il a perçu au bout du sentier
lucas un de ses camarades qui venait
parfois ne rejoindre et bavarder avec
lui
guillaume mais c'est de l'intérieur
claude guéant juge
il pousse à écrire
au dessus du rhône dans un gargouillis
mandeau remuer le brame vient de surgir
et nord noir l'oeil allumer sa gueule
rouge menaçante
il déploie ses ailes des cayes lance son
horrible mugissement et se jette sur
guillaume il saisit le garçon qui se
débat et serrant sa proie hurlantes
entre ses griffes n'emporte dans les
airs vers le fleuve de l'enfant il ne
reste qu'un sabots sur la rive
l'udc a paralysé par la frayeur demeure
quelques secondes sans bouger puis
brusquement il prend ses jambes à son
cou et court jusqu'à la maison de
guillaume julia préparer le repas
le brame le brame appris votre fils la
mère hurle de douleur
tout de suite elle se précipite au
dehors coupe par les chauds pour
atteindre plus vite le fleuve les
chardons lui griffe les jambes des
chauves-souris la frôle de leur zèle le
hibou et la nuit vient mais julien court
court il faut sauver guillaume retrouver
la trace du monstre hélas parvenu au
bord du fleuve
julia ne voit que les vaches qui
broutent dans le noir le brame n'a
laissé aucune trace
la femme se laisse tomber sur la rive en
pleurant à quelques mètres du sabot que
l'obscurité lui cache
tenant toujours le petit vacher entre
ses griffes le monstre avait plongé dans
le rhône au contact de l'eau glacée qui
lui entré dans les yeux le nez la gorge
guillaume s'était débattu de plus belle
en vain mais cruel griffe se resserrer
sur lui
le garçon est tout fait suffoquer
finalement il s'était évanoui et voilà
qu'il ouvrait les yeux sous l'eau dans
une caverne sombre plein de guest et de
sacs en désordre ou rien d'un profond
silence des poissons aux yeux glauque
nageaient autour de lui et lui lancer
des coups de nageoires il crut que des
serpents glissait sur son visage c'était
deux grandes algues brunes qui flottait
une gueule ouverte rouge pleine de dents
pointues se pencha sur lui je ne te
dévoreraient pas dit le brame
enfin pas tout de suite
tiens pas encore un peu de ce breuvage
il te permettra de respirer dans l'eau
comme un poisson
le brame préparé lui même cette espèce
de potions à base de poudre d'os et des
cayes
il l'avait ensuite dans des flacons et
la ministre est à certaines de ses
victimes qu'il désirait garder quelques
temps comme domestique pour nettoyer sa
caverne et ses entrepôts toi mon garçon
je t'ai entendu chanter tout à l'heure
quand tu gardes étaient vache tu vas
rester ici et me tenir compagnie le
brame enferma guillaume dans une cage
aux barreaux de fer il pris soin de la
fermer à clé puis l'accrocha au plafond
de la caverne les supplications du
pauvre vache et ne servir à rien quel
terreur pour lui de se sentir ainsi en
prison accompli sans pouvoir se tenir
debout
avec la pensée de ne sortir de cette
cage que pour être dévoré sur la rive
julia pleurait toujours tout à coup un
bruit de ram sur l'eau la fit sursauter
une forme blanche qui conduisait une
barque s'approchait d'elle c'était un
personnage squelettiques couvert de
voile qui dissimulait son corps et une
partie de son visage on ne devine est
que ces orbites creux il parla d'une
voix sépulcrale je suis le fantôme du
crépuscule
tu cherches ton fils
le brame vient de l'emporter au fond du
fleuve dans sa caverne sur la rive
droite tu es sur la rive gauche du
fleuve
je peux te faire traverser
si tu me donnes en échange tes cheveux
ils sont noirs les miens blanchissent je
veux les renouveler la femme soupira
mais sans hésiter défi son chignon le
fantôme ramasse un couteau dans sa
barque et d'un coup sec tranche à la
natte de julia
puis il fit monter la femme à ses côtés
le fleuve rouler ses eaux noires de gros
nuages s'accumulaient dans le ciel le
fantôme ramet cézeaux ça y est sous les
voiles
la femme grelottait elle arriva sur
l'autre rive
dès qu'elle eut mis pied à terre le
fantôme disparu en ricanant dans le
brouillard
comment faire pour descendre au fond du
fleuve
julia ne savait pas nager si elle plonge
et c'était la mort la malheureuse
essayer de réfléchir
c'est alors que dans un rayon de lune
qui se glissait entre deux nuages
elle vit bouge et les roses ou un grand
serpent au gendre envers elle se
dressait la tête en avant la gorge empli
de venin il siffla projeta vers la femme
sa langue fourchue que vient du fer dans
mon domaine
julia s'expliqua le serpent s'enroule
assure lui même est paru ce calme et je
peux te donner un breuvage qui te
permettra de respirer dans l'eau il
fouilla dans la vase et en ramenant un
flacon de potions ayant appartenu au
brame un jour que le monstre chat cette
odeur de jeunes brochet qui s'amusaient
près de la caverne avait dérobé ce
flacon de breuvages s'en servant comme
d'un ballon à coups de tête et de
nageoires il l'avait poussé vers la
surface puis abandonnée dans les roseaux
le serpent s'en était emparé julia
tendit la main vers le flacon d'abord tu
dois me payer 10 de serpents jaune tu as
des dents solides donne moi tes canine
maigrot avenant 1 commence à s'user il
m'en faudrait de 9
la femme se cacher la tête dans les
mains
elle imagine à la douleur pourtant elle
dit oui
se servant de sa langue fourchue comme
d'une paire de tenailles le serpent lui
arracha deux canines julia se retint
pour ne pas hurler
lorsqu'il sentit des trous à la place de
7 dans l' angoisse l'envahir enfin le
serpent jaune ni remis le flacon et
s'éloigna dans les roseaux julia bull le
breuvage et plonge l'eau grise l'aveuglé
à l'asphyxié elle cru qu'elle allait se
noyer
le serpent lui avait démenti non au bout
de quelques secondes le breuvage fit son
effet julia smit à respirer et feed
grande brasse désherbe flottante
s'entortille est autour de ses mollets
c'était gluant abominable un poisson si
la mort dit à l'épaule elle atterrit au
fond du fleuve sur un banc de cailloux
devant un jardin entouré d'une aide
cactus aux énormes piquant ce ne pouvait
être que la propriété du brame
mais comment entrer il n'y avait pas de
porte
l'endroit était désert pas un bruit sur
le fond limoneux une barque échouée
prenait l'eau de toutes parts et achever
de pourrir le coeur de julia matin fort
cette solitude
ce silence était impressionnant
la femme fit un pas vers la halte là
pourquoi vient troubler notre sommeil
demanda le plus grand des cactus dont
les piquants se hérissaient tous
ensemble les autres cactus tournaire
leurs épines vers julia on aurait dit
une arme et menaçante jeu je vais voir
le brame murmure à la pauvre mère de
guillaume tu veux dire que tu viens te
faire dévorer ricanant un petit cactus a
l'air méchant je cherche mon fils eh
bien nous te laisseront passer décida le
grand cactus mais à une condition
avec l'automne les eaux du rhône
deviennent de plus en plus froide nous
gloton il faut que tu nous réchauffe et
julia réchauffer les cactus en les
serrant contre sa poitrine pour leur
donner sa chaleur les piquants pénétrait
dans sa peau la déchirait la femme ne
pouvait s'empêcher de gémir tout ses
aiguilles les vêtements de julia était
en lambeaux ses bras couverts
d'égratignures saignait quant à lui
réchauffer le dernier catus
celui-ci repli à ses feuilles pour
laisser passer julia elle le pénétra
dans le jardin vous pousser des fleurs
de verre étrange aux couleurs sombres
noires grises violette des ossements de
toutes sortes parsemer les années çà et
là traînait aussi une casquette de
bateliers un fichu de lavandières un
jouet d'enfant
voilà tout ce qui restait des victimes
du monstre la femme avancé le coeur
plein d'angoissé dans le sinistre jardin
ses pieds meurtris la porte est à peine
revers et et guillaume ou détour d'une
allée à l'aperçu la caverne sombre
creusé dans le rocher sur le côté droit
du fleuve cette caverne paraissait
profonde des sacs des tonneaux empilés
dans la boue l'encombraient partout sur
le sol des arêtes de poisson sur les
murs couraient des araignées d'eau un
rat nageait parmi quelques tablettes
guillaume à plat doucement julia
personne ne répondit la femme fait
encore quelques pas elle lève la tête et
découvre au plafond la grande cage julia
s'approche encore et que vaut-elle non
ce n'est pas possible
elle voit guillaume accompli contre les
barreaux de la cage
les yeux fermés morts non
endormi mais six balles et des traces de
larmes sur ses jours guillaume c'est moi
ta mère qui elle n'a pas le temps de
finir sa phrase
un mugissement terrible ébranle la
caverne surgit des profondeurs le brame
se dresse devant julia mes yeux du
monstre est un sel sa longue queue vrac
à snow de ses naseaux palpitant sortent
des flammes
sa gorge ce coffre il va éclater de cola
et ré ouvre sa gueule rouge aux dents
pointues femme qui t'a permis
jamais jamais personne avant toi n'a
franchi le seuil de la caverne
malheur à toi julia tremble de la tête
aux pieds
réveillé brusquement dans sa cage fermée
à clé guillaume épouvanté de voir sa
mère dans ce lieu maudit s'accroche au
barreau et supplie épargné la julia se
jette à genoux devant les griffes du
monstre s'il vous plaît rendez moi mon
enfant le brame temps son long cou vers
la femme elle s'en passer sur elle le
souffle glacé du monstre son haleine
pestilentielle lui donne la nausée
nico tu pas dit le brame ton fils je
vais le dévorer devant toi pour te punir
et je te dévore et ensuite julia se tord
les mains
je vous en prie ne le tuez pas rendez
lui sa liberté
ensuite vous ferez de moi ce que vous
voudrez pendant quelques instants le
brame l'observent dans sa cage guillaume
tourné vers sa mère sanglote
et voilà que le brame pose une pattes
griffues sur l'épaule de julia il ya de
grands yeux et tu sembles voir très
clair moi je suis un peu myope ça me
gêne pour chasser alors je te propose un
échange tu me donnes tes yeux je te
rends ton fils après tout la vue c'est
encore plus utile que les chansons je
lis à quoi qu'il va s'évanouir
à ses yeux ce qu'elle a de plus précieux
non le plus précieux c'est son fils
d'accord murmure-t-elle tout pâle
guillaume a beau protester non non mr ne
fait pas cela
julia temps ses paupières aux griffes du
monstre déjà le brame se réjouit déjà
il avance une patte cruel pour saisir
les yeux de julia
déjà il non il n'est pas le tout de
faire d'autres gestes
brusquement un fracas semblable au bruit
d'une explosion
les eaux du rhône ou de 20 secondes du
multi use elle se précipitaient rouler
entraîner dans leur tourbillon le brame
julia la cage dont les barreaux se
fracasse air sous le poids des eaux
libérèrent guillaume qui fut à son tour
projeter comme y ait emporté et de même
le rat les araignées les poissons tout
filet à une allure vertigineuse dans le
flou devenu fou on le voyait plus clair
à cause de la boue remuer des ald
s'arracher le fleuve grondait et son
grondement couvrait les cris du brame et
ceux de julia et de guillaume et que se
passait-il le barrage craquer non mais
les habitants du village prévenu par
lucas avait décidé d'ouvrir les vannes
toutes les vannes pour que les eaux
retenu déferle et par leur violence
chasse le brame de son repaire
maintenant armé de faux de fourche 2h
les paysans guidé par lucas court vers
le pré où le monstre enlevé guillaume
des femmes portent des lampes tempêtes
pour éclairer la nuit
d'ailleurs la lune se montrer brille sur
le rhône transformée en un gigantesque
torrent
les hommes se sont juré qu'il tuerait le
brame et délivrerait s'il était encore
temps julia et le petit va chez le flou
sauvage fait tournoyer guillaume et sa
mère
les rejette les reprend et les pousses
jusque vers la surface du fleuve
il dérive dans le courant furieux parmi
toutes sortes d'épaves julia s'agrippe à
un tronc d'arbre déraciné guillaume
s'accroche à la coque de la barque
englouti chassé du fond des eaux
ils crient au secours les villageois
l'ont repéré ainsi que julia courage
nous arrivons des hommes munis de
longues perches essaie d'accrocher le
garçon et la femme par leur ceinture
plusieurs fois il échoue guillaume et sa
mère semble à bout de forces
enfin dans un dernier effort il se
cramponne au perche le flou les
repousses ils vont l'art chez nous ils
tiennent bon l'un après l'autre on les
tire de l'eau déchaîné il claque des
dents mais ils sont sauvés le brame
aussi fait surface des cris de frayeur
et de rage accueille son apparition dans
la nuit à la lumière des lampes tempêtes
il semble plus monstrueux encore que
dans le jour jamais on l'avait
d'approcher d'aussi près sa gueule de
requins crash et recrache l'eau
bouillante il grande ouvrant ses lourdes
tél
ils cherchent à s'envoler pour fuir mais
les villageois le guette
ils lancent sur lui des pierres des hd
et pieux alors le brame plongée nage en
se cachant sous l'eau cependant il
ressurgit poussé par le courant sauvages
on lui crie des injures les bâtons les
faux les faux cils lancé par des mâts
vigoureuse pleuvent sur lui
ils échappent ils nagent plus loin les
paysans cours sur la rive pour le
rattraper il se retourne les menaces de
ses dents pointues leur lance des jets
de flammes par les masos la lutte dure
toute la nuit
soudain à l'instant même où le soleil se
lève une fourche envoyé avec force
atteint le brame se plante dans son
flanc une dernière fois on voit briller
son acte cruel
l'écho répercute sont faits terribles
brusquement le monstre coule dans le
fleuve disparaît los colores d'une tache
rose
on n'a jamais revu le monstre du fleuve
est il mort ce n'est pas sûr
on entend parfois mugir dans les défilés
de la donzelle là où le rhône s'étrangle
entre les rochers peut-être le brame
ont-ils encore les rives du fleuve à la
recherche d'un promeneur solitaire ou
d'un petit berger qui emportera dans ses
griffes au fond de l'eau quand la nuit
tombe pour le dévorer
[Musique]